hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game between alpha zero and
stock fish and this time it's gonna be a
very nice game in the nimzo-indian
defense so we've seen them battling it
out using a lot of different opening
choices this is another game that was
played using the TCC at the top chess
engine championship 2016 opening books
and some first eight or nine moves are
are from that book so I don't think they
would go for the nimzo-indian willingly
but it's interesting to see what comes
out out of this opening that was played
so many times but you know we wouldn't
be be having this privilege without
forcing him to do so so without further
ado let's check out how the game went
with d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 this is not the
nimzo-indian defense we have III the
main line and now c5 this is still the
main line we've pushed up to d3 the
hypno variation nice to see six sorry
about that Knight to f3 and now be a
bishop capture since e3 B captures on c3
and now d6 and here we have E for
expanding in the center and now h6 and
from here this position was reached
several times in in human chess and here
known and some of the known moves were
castles and also Queen to c2 but here
alpha plays a move that was not played
before we have E 5 and now for a move 9
we already have a new position on the
board so let's see what what was alphas
idea would this ePHI move D captures on
e5 with Knight captures on e5 seek a
press on d4 Knight captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and here stockfish has to
make a decision well of course you do
want to castle but if you castle here
prematurely well not after B captures in
c6 but after all four castles stop
Fischer has to make a choice whether it
will castle but if so castles then you
get C seek after Sun B for alpha gets a
very nice center here and of course you
will not be able to capture because of a
bishop to h7 check you will lose the
d4 so after castles by alpha Stockbridge
decides to play D captures on c3 so
already this is only moved 12 stockfish
has a very nice pass pawn on c3
but he's Hindi stuck in the center so
offer takes this opportunity and plays
Bishop to a 3 and from this move Bishop
to e3 this has only moved 13 you will
see how stockfish struggles for the rest
of the game to develop to develop his
pieces and somehow castle now that the
bishop is on a3 black or no longer has
the darks worship alpha is controlling
this diagonal and it will be very hard
for black to castle one idea one idea is
to play Queen c7 push c5 blocked at the
dark square Bishop and then castle other
idea is to move the knight push the F
pawn like king f7 and then bring the
rook over this way so quinta c7
stockfish already wants to play C 5
alpha prevents this with the Queen to f3
and of course see if I would be a
terrible blunder as you're gonna lose
the rook on a 8 so after Queen to f3
first looked to be a now against c5 is a
big a big threat but alpha prevents it
with a beautiful move Bishop to c5
keeping this pawn stuck on c6 and now
you can see that it's not that easy for
black to develop still the king is stuck
here the bishop is still controlling all
the important dark squares on this
diagonal developing the bishop doesn't
really do all that much for black as the
c6 bone will be will be somewhat
bothersome and here you can choose a
couple of different approaches an
interesting approaches rook the b2 seems
like a very active line for stockfish
but then after rook F to e1 and Bishop
to b7 you you have to be careful about
ideas like Bishop to g6 this would be
very dangerous and it's one of the
problems that black faces due to this
dark square bishop controlling this
diagonal now after F capture some g6 you
get Queen captures on the c3 and now you
see the problem of the rook and b2 the
rook has to move and there really is no
where to move you have to go to b6 in
front of the bishop but now comes rope
captures on e6 King to f7 and now
37 will win the Queen captures captures
and after keen captures black will have
some material compensation for the Queen
but to due to an awkward position of the
king this rook and this rug being
undeveloped white will have plenty of
compensation c5 attacks the rook rook
moves now Queen e5 checking newsroom d1
check King moves Queen e6 check King
moves and now after Queen to f7 it will
be very hard hard to parry the threats
of rook to be won for example 95 now
rook to be won and to prevent checkmate
on b7 black will have to give up some
material and now white will definitely
have more than enough material to win
this game but it's only one of the
problems of playing such an active move
too early while the king is still stuck
in the center so stockfish has to find a
different plan first 'if I've the the
point is very nicely protected by the
Queen 95 also now the bush can prohibit
the bishop can perhaps enter the game
we have rook to e1 now again stockfish
alpha could be planning some ideas with
Bishop to g6
so now bush of the e6 and now the
putting pressure on the c4 pawn but also
there is less pressure along the e file
against the black king but now Queen to
g3 a very nice move by alpha now
threatening the e5 pawn twice but also
going after the g7 pawn and also if this
bishop ever moves the c3 pawn will also
become a target the c3 pawn is a very
strong passed pawn but it's also a
pretty big target so still hard to
decide what to do here and here a stock
Fischer doesn't want the King to stay in
the center and it plays Knight to h5
with an attack on the Queen also defends
the g7 pawn and here alpha could
definitely snatch the e5 pawn but then
after Queen captures rook captures then
you get Knight to f4 and going after the
bishop here and after Bishop Bishop to
f1 then even c2 is coming group 2 b1
will be an idea and stop Fischer will
have sold it's problems here
so after Knight to h5 alpha goes Queen
to e3 simply keeping the tension and now
stop your skin is still in the center so
how do you how do you do something here
first
Knight to f4 an excellent square for
tonight and also now f6 can be played to
make room on f7 for the King but you'll
see just how much problems stockfish
will have because of this plan Knight to
h5 to f4 to make room for f6 to
artificially castle to bring the rook
into the game and how how well alpha
will take advantage of this so here you
could snatch the pawn here there's
definitely time to snatch this point if
you capture the pawn rook moves attack
the bishop bishop goes back nothing
really changed you did snatch a point
you've created a very strong past eight
point but then black plays f6 King get
seven and alpha thinks that this time is
too valuable to add to trade for only
one pawn so instead push of the c2 not
allowing this Knight to snatch the
strong bishop and now it's not first
move with f6 as planned that the King
will now come to f7 and alpha still
ignores the pawn so first h4 we have
Queen to a5 now protecting the c3 pawn
and also putting pressure on the Bishop
on c5 but now rook a to be one now the
threat is the rook captures unbe eight
as the rooks are still not connected so
King to f7 now the rooks are connected
and here you have to decide what to do
here alpha plays g3 and this we can say
is a really really a wonderful critical
moment of the game where stalkerish has
to decide what to do with this knight on
F for bringing the Knight to f4 with
this maneuver from f6 to h5 to f4
allowed f6 to be played the King to come
to f7 and all of the developing moves
basically that followed were possible
due to this knight move they're all
moves so what do you do with the knight
now
well if you wouldn't like to h3 that's a
bit of a problem
King G - now there is a lot of pressure
on the knight the bishop asked to keep
protecting it and it's a hard hard to
say what a black plays here let's say
rook to be to you attack the bishop rook
captures pawn captures rook to be one
attacks the pawn but now after rook to
b8 white could play a three and now
everything is protected the bishop is
protecting the a3 pawn black constantly
has to worry about the b2 pawn and the
bishop can't really move the knight this
night is stuck on H the
so stockfish doesn't like this for black
as the night would definitely be
stranded there another possibility to
perhaps free the night is night to h5
but this also is not possible because
here white has this excellent Bishop to
d6 move and now you force black the
trade along the B file rope capture some
b1 root capture some b1 now threatening
Bishop to be 7 and after up to d7 I look
to the 8th Bishop to be a rook to b7
check roadblocks and now you have this
Queen to f3 a wonderful move that
attacks the night here so you cannot
capture here because now you're getting
checkmated Queen captures on a5 check on
h5 check g6 and Queen captures will be
checkmate so here after this powerful
Queen to have three move you would have
to protect the night let's say g6 but
now comes Queen captures on c6 and again
black is falling apart here so stock
fish doesn't like what's happening here
after g3 and tries a different plan we
have Queen captures on a 2 here stock
which says ok you capture my knight I'll
capture your discipline c2 but here we
have Queen to e4
of course capturing the c3 pawn does
guard the bishop but then you lose if
you play something like nice d2 check
and black of course will win the game as
of course if you if you captured the
rook then rock it if capture denied and
rope captures and then you get rogue
captures on be one with check and
another thing even if Queen captures on
c3 is the rook captures and b1 in
immediately that's even worse for white
because now you either capture with the
rook and face and nights to eat to check
and you lose the Queen or if you capture
with the bishop then again 93 to check
the knight is now protected from the
quote by the Queen rope captures you
will lose the exchange and of course now
the row can enter the game you will also
lose the game so after this Queen
captures an e to alpha does not go after
the c3 pawn but rather Queen to e4 now
again it's hard to say what do you do
with this Knight hear you it's very hard
to trade along the B file because the
white will always control the B file and
you don't want to allow roped
to be seven if the knight moves then
even Queen to g6 becomes possible Queen
captures and c6 is a threat so here
black plays Queen captures on c4 offers
the trade of Queens here and it's
interesting here if you if you actually
capture the Queen Queen captures Bishop
captures now you can actually capture
the knight here alpha would be upper
piece but then a5 and here you can see
that stock which has four pawns for four
alphas extra piece and out of those
pawns here you already have a past a
pawn a past C pawn there's the other C
pawn behind and black would definitely
have compensation alpha doesn't like
this so after Queen captures on c4 we
have Queen captures on c6 and now you
have this huge huge threat of Queen to
c7 check that's why I alpha decided to
go for this line instead of that as now
it's not really not possible to prevent
Queen to c7 check here we have nice - d3
but this is what I meant it's very hard
to decide what to do instead of bringing
this Knight over to d3 and you do want
to play something for example if you
play nice to eat you check it doesn't
work because white will simply capture
the night and then if you capture back
you get Queen to c7 check King moves and
now you were getting checkmate it here
after mushroom to see it you will
capture it and it's it's all over as the
bishop is controlling the h7 Square but
even without that after Knight to e2
check after rook captures an e2 you
can't capture with the Queen you could
capture with the rook rook captures and
b1 but then Bishop captures and again
you've achieved really nothing here
white is still up a piece with with a
much better game so other than that
other than the moon stocks which play
Knight to d3 and I to e to check is not
possible if you go nice to h3 again this
Bishop will be overloaded guarding the
night king h2 and now after you try to
bring the rook over into the game it
will still not be possible rook captures
rook captures Queen to c7 check wins the
rook so definitely not possible so after
this Queen captures on c6 we have nice
three stock Beshear goes for a line that
offers him some counter play but for the
loss of a lot of material alpha place
rook captures nb8 we have rook after
sandy eight and now of course Queen to
c7 check it was not possible to prevent
this we have King to g6 and now comes
virtual captures on d3 Queen captures on
d3 and only now Queen captures on b8 and
here we have Bishop to d5 so alpha is
now up a whole rook but stockfish has
some compensation with having extra
points extra three pawns but also if
alpha makes a slow move like for example
capturing a pond and after Queen f3
stock fish is winning here it's you know
it will not be possible to bury all of
these made threats
so after Bishop to d5 we have King to h2
a very nice defensive resource by alpha
now Queen to f3 will not be possible
because Queen b1 check and after the
King moves now rook g1 and now you
cannot capture of course the bishop is
guarding here you're controlling the C 2
square so you cannot start pushing the
pawn and the white will be able to
defend here and in the end have a better
position so after King 2 h2 we have C 2
immediately by stock fish but now comes
Queen to be to keeping an eye on the C 1
square we have a 5 story starts pushing
the other pawn queen 2 c1
now going for Queen to e3 we have a 4
and Queen to e3 alpha now wants to
exchange Queens we have Queen captures
and now comes F captures and e3 so now
the rook is controlling the c1 squared
the bishop is controlling the a3 square
and now it's very interesting stock fish
alpha is still up a whole rook but a
stock fish still has a lot of pests
dangerous pass pawns the problem is both
of these pawns Queen on a dark square
and stock fish has a light square bishop
so it will be very hard for this bishop
to support the pawns also a3 is a dark
square so it's very unlikely that you
will be able to pass this Square but
okay King to a5 it will be interesting
how alpha makes progress here also
kingi one King to e4 going now
if black can get his King to f3 it will
be very hard for white so King to f2
and
now Bishop to e6 n okay we have King to
e2 Bishop to g4 check and King to d2 now
the king is also protecting the e3 pawn
but also preventing the C pawn from
cleaning so now perhaps drew can get
activated Bishop to d1
but now comes Luke to f1 with f5 and now
comes Luke 2 F 2 G 6 and now be sure to
a3 a very nice move and now it's hard
for black to make a move you could play
h5 but at some point you will run out of
moves and you will have to move the
bishop or you will move the King and
then white will grab much more space
because at the moment the bishop is on a
three
the a four point cannot go further and
also it's covering the C 1 square so you
can either play a move like h5 and then
white will simply waste time look if one
look after rook F 1 until black decides
to move either the King or the bishop so
stockfish decides to move the bishop
instead of this h5 move immediately
Bishop to g4 and now comes King captures
and c2 grabbing the seat upon but giving
up the e3 pawn king capture Sonny 3 and
now Bishop to c5 with check King to e4
and now comes King to d2 are really
taking away pretty much all of the
squares for the black king the black
King can go to d5 but first we have g5
Bishop to FF a bishop to f8 by alpha
going after the h6 pawn and now f4 also
possible is G captures on h4 and then
after G captures on h4 h5 also a
possibility but now after Bishop to d6
it will be very hard for black to do to
do anything for example F if you play f4
simply King g1 King d5 now comes rook to
d2 check King 24 and now look to a 2 you
will eliminate this pawn and then the
other pawns will fall very soon so after
Bishop to f8 we have f4 immediately by
stockfish G captures on f 4g captures on
f4 and now King to e1 Bishop to e6
now comes Luke to D 2 and now King to f5
so stockfish is still trying but here
after rook to the 8th this is move four
and it was in this position that
Stockbridge decided to resign the game
so we should resign the game rather it
did not make a move but I want such
possibility I would be to play something
like h5 let's say not maybe h6 spawn a
target but then again we have this very
strong Bishop to d6 move and it's it's
not possible for black to not make any
moves here you could try something like
e 4 but then look to f8 and you're gonna
lose DF for pawn after the king moves
king g6 rook captures you're gonna start
losing all the pawns and if you don't
put efore for example after Bishop to d6
you could go for something like Bishop
to b3 just try and go back and forth
with the bishop
hoping you could make a draw but it
doesn't work
rook to e8 now you pressure this point
immediately and now after you block
Bishop to e6 then King to f2 you will
slowly but surely start getting your
King into the game and at some point you
will well you will either have to move
the King face check and then you will
lose this pawn whatever you do you will
you will start losing material
so after rook to d8 stock free decided
to resign the game and a very nice
victory for alpha here in the
nimzo-indian like we said it's not that
these positions that arrived from from
opening books are of some meaning but
it's very interesting if you plug in
someone who plays the the nimzo-indian
defense for example here up to this move
h6 you could very well have this
position on the board and then you will
know ok it's possible to play e5 and you
will have some creative ideas on how to
go about this maybe you will win this
diagonal maybe maybe you will also not
in this exact same position but maybe in
other positions you will also be in a
position where I don't know it's a
similar similar idea and then you will
find this Bishop to c5 move to not allow
your opponent to consolidate with c5 a
lot a lot of interesting ideas in this
game which I hope you will also be able
to use in your own games at some point
in your life then
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah thank you as you can see up
there in the in the info corner
yesterday we had 1600 no sorry yes 1650
new subscribers joined our Channel
so very glad you decided that YouTube
will not force you to to unsubscribe
against your will and yeah definitely
welcome to each and every one of you so
I would like to thank Emily one of a
Robert Kieffer in from hajjaj D was
raised as a beggar and Nieto and team of
soccer for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video so your think all for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting games thank you all and
I'll see you soon